all right now welcoming here on the rich
eisen show
is somebody whose camera has been
working
and it has been working uh to capture
some images
and some stories of someone he's known
for quite some time that person's name
is uh dwayne johnson and fans of dwayne
johnson aka the rock
uh which means every human being on
planet earth will love this
it's called through the lens dwayne
johnson the rock his life
his movies his world the president of
production of seven bucks production
producer and photographer all
hyphenate irem garcia good to see you
sir
uh likewise thanks so much for having me
on what a wonderful intro i appreciate
that
hey that's what i do for a living this
is what i do
you got a future my friend you got a
good future and so how long
when did you first meet dwayne when did
you first i met look i met dwayne
um back when i was about 15. uh you know
i met him i was a fresher you know i was
early in high school freshman sophomore
he was in college uh and i remember at
that time thinking you know i was pretty
tall for a for a freshman high school
and i met this dude and he was a
mountain
uh he was a mountain of a man and he was
dating my sister at the time and i
remember just thinking you know
hopefully he's good to her because i'm
going to need a big bat if he's not
[Laughter]
right and so you guys just hit it off
pretty much through that relationship
yeah
yeah right from the beginning we hit it
off and very similar minded
and you know at that time we bonded over
um
over the sega genesis playing nhl hockey
uh and
we kind of we bonded over that and and
over sports and obviously him as a
football player and over time
we just um we just stayed close and
we've always been creative partners me
him and danny have always you know
whether he was doing the character of
the rock i would help him with that
dialogue
and when he got into the into the film
business i remember i was in between
jobs i was trying to figure out what i
was going to do
um because i what i had studied in in
college didn't i i really didn't like
that career
and he said hey why don't you come with
me to do scorpion king let's i've never
done it before let's see how we like it
and that was a moment when i realized i
wanted to be a film producer and we've
uh
kind of stayed steady since hit it off
ever since so
yeah yeah i know prior to me hitting
record on this
you said that we know a lot of the same
people um does that mean
if you met dwayne in college you met
warren sapp did you meet warren
i never got a chance to be warren i wish
i would have got a chance to meet warren
i didn't you know i only my dwayne was
my contact tool but man
you know those those those string of
players that he crossed path with from
warren to to ray uh all those guys i
mean especially that period of time
of the canes were unbelievable and uh
and that's when they were still
fire you know and uh and so he comes
from that that lineage of unbelievable
players and and i do remember
i think i have a football that he um
was very kind to get signed for me i
think from maybe the 91 team with all
those players just
legends on there so it was really cool
and uh in a really cool period in time
when he was there
i know um you know he he was part of a
pretty damn good football team you know
back in the day he had some i miss those
days my friend i have hopes for us now
but
it's been a long time since uh since we
had that that that that juice and
i'm hoping it comes back well look man i
mean the canes are
it's tough to keep them down even though
they might be going through some down
years so
where did you come up with the idea of
you know of doing this i mean as if you
don't have enough on your plate
of being a producer of one of the
hardest working guys in this town right
now
i mean where did you come with the idea
of like let's start taking some pictures
sure well you know it's one of those
things where the dream was to
produce films and once i i started
achieving that dream
i started noticing things were just
flying by and i really wanted to
document these moments and these
these special um triumphs we were having
and so
just for the fun of it just documenting
some some shots being able to share them
with friends and family we're always
away from it and obviously dj's
pretty active on social media so he
loves to have images that he can share
and there was a period where i wanted to
give him a gift
and trust me there's nothing harder than
giving a gift to the biggest
movie star in the world look the people
around you rich they know when they try
and give you a gift it's not easy when
you
when you're dealing with superstars like
you so uh you're right
by the way you are right i am the the
rock
yeah that's how it goes i can recognize
it i recognize it from afar
um and so i wanted to give them an image
just a cool image framed and as i was
going through it
i remember thinking wow i haven't
actually had a shot a chance to look
through all these images and
i ended up just sharing a bunch of them
with dj we both came away saying you
know what we think there might be
something here there's some really cool
stories behind these images
a lot of these photos people have never
seen and it might be fun to
to create something that we can share
with fans and and also a great creative
outlet for me just to exercise another
muscle and so from there i ran with it
and um
found a great partner in st martin's and
here we are now man it's really cool
and it's where all uh books are
available right now the rock through the
lens his life his movie his world again
20 plus years worth of photographs of
you in in in your relationship with him
uh is there one that leaps to mind that
you'd love for people just to hey you
got to get this book because of
you know of that you know i think look i
think there's
there's a couple images there we know
one image that always stands out to me
is one i
was able to capture of him and stan lee
um i've always loved that image stan lee
was was one of the guys that
when dj first broke into the business
coming from wrestling
um stan just greeted him with open arms
and he just felt that
dj had something to offer the business
and and the moment i captured in that
book
was many years later they hadn't been
able to see each other
and stan was just so proud of everything
dj done he's like i always knew you were
going to do this kid
and i knew you were gonna be big into
this business and he's just heaping
praise on to dj looking
you've met dj before he's a monster
right six four 275 pounds of muscle but
he's
a sweetheart inside and in that image
you know i always love that you could
see him being humbled
and it was uh it was for me because i
had never met stan before so
that's an image i've always been proud
of but i also think just in the book
you're gonna see some looks of dj you
know that you've just never seen some
very intimate moments because he's very
generous and
and i was able to capture those and
place them in the book and um
so what how's he doing right now i know
that he he's doing great
you know he and yes he and his family
were had contracted
uh coveted and kind of took a lot of
people back because he is obviously the
embodiment
of uh health fitness as well as um
savvy and and and and somebody that uh
you know is not gonna really put himself
out there at risk uh is he doing all
right everybody doing okay he is he's
doing very well and luckily him and and
lauren and the kids are all doing well
um but you know they got they got hit
hard they got hit hard and i remember
there was a period of time we're always
in touch and even though we've been
you know far apart quarantining we
always stay close and he'd gone
quiet for a while and you know how as he
is he he keeps things
on the low as he was battling it and
then he he uh he let me know what
happened and it was it was a shock but
but you know thank god him and the
family are okay and
and you know they they were able to
bounce back but he's doing well now and
he's thriving and
you know he's fully recovered and now
we're just back at work so very very
grateful for that
and in terms of at work i mean what is
it like
shooting movies or getting ready to
prepare shooting movies in what's going
on
in the world with the pandemic i know
you know what you know what i'm doing
with nfl network and the protocols just
to walk in that building
i'm wondering what it's been like for
you yeah you're look you're in it it's
an incredible undertaking right and it
literally took
all the months while we were in
quarantine you know we got shot done in
march
um and i'd say probably starting from
april on
began the process of just figuring out
how do we bring everyone back in a safe
way and it's
uh you know manuals being created with
hundreds of pages and you know just the
the protocols of testing multiple
testing
times a week and sequestering crew and
creating bubbles for
safety um you know ppe procedures uh
you know in terms of groups that are
able to you know we have zones that
certain only certain groups are allowed
to go to just
you know we've had a great partner in
netflix to do something like this
and they've their approach has been
whatever it takes to keep everyone safe
is what we're gonna do
um so we've been fortunate to have him
as a partner and we've had great success
we're back up and running now and
um you know it but it has not been easy
this world right now doing it
it's not an easy thing but once as we
pick up speed things get easier and
we've been very efficient and the most
important thing is we've been safe and
that's that's
that was a priority for us what are you
working on right now what's good so
we're continuing we were shooting
something called red notice
for uh netflix and we had uh we we got
shut down in march because of uh the
pandemic and
now we were presumed so we're halfway
through it's with gal gadot ryan
reynolds and dwayne and it's
a big fun movie and we've had to adjust
in terms of how we're doing because we
were actually going to be shooting in
italy
uh when everything went down so we've
readjusted and and we've uh
adjusted so that we can finish
everything up on stages but
really proud of our crew how we rally
lead and our team
and our cast in terms of just how
everyone's embraced this and
and um getting back to work and getting
our crew back to work and it's been very
successful
and you're from jersey right where we're
where yeah yeah i'm from jersey i grew
up in jersey in morse county
uh suck a son in new jersey and then i
went down to
miami to go to the u for college i'm
from staten island so that's kind of
like oh right on
you know i mean it's technically right
it you know there's parts
in the area that would definitely uh
proclaim staten island as its own
sprinkles how does one uh from jersey
by way of miami wind up a raider fan
like you i've been told
look i i tell you i get that a lot it's
funny so i'm you know i'm
uh the child of immigrant parents from
cuba and so
typically you know sports are passed on
you know from parents from your dad kind
of passes it on to you
um they didn't follow sports they really
you know our first foray into football
was
at an amazing time was the u you know
during you know starting in 85 was when
we started following the canes but
i really wanted to follow a team and no
team was resonating with me and it was
around 89.
um bo knows i got struck by bo nose and
i followed the
the combo i thought that combo of bo
jackson and marcus allen
was so awesome and i'm a loyal guy and
uh and i've been a raiders fan since and
look i always say there's one thing you
know if you meet a raiders fan if
they're a raiders fan
i'm clearly not a front runner so i love
my team
i love my team and i'm with them to the
end and we're turning the corner i'm
really excited what groon is doing over
there and look we want to know
i'll take it all day oh i know and this
kid josh jacobs is a special
player i don't know if you're if you're
fully aware of his story
it might be something that you and you
know dwayne might be interested in
talking to him about about
how he grew up and what he's overcome
and what he is
so powerful you know i mean when he got
the house for his father
and and it's just a beautiful a
beautiful story and an amazing player
what a young player and
he gets that hat trick on on sunday i
mean
it's really exciting to see what they're
doing and look as a raiders fan you just
you're like you know it's eventually got
to come around right like eventually
it's gonna circle back around and i feel
like we're on the upswing
so if we red notice is what you're
saying you're shooting right now correct
yes suddenly there happens to now
suddenly out of nowhere
be an on location shoot for the film in
las vegas that's where we can
connect the dots for you 100 you you
will see it for sure
if we're shooting uh you know in the
death star and whatever
you know what they're calling it
you'll know that there's some some
personal motivations there for why
suddenly our third act is just being
shot in the middle of that stadium
it looks perfect right doesn't it look
like okay
it is the ultimate raiders even from
outside i remember when they were
building and you just see that shiny
black dome and you're like oh yeah
you don't even have to ask who else
would play here but i'm silver and black
hey man um congrats on this it's real
it's really an amazing
book i mean some of these photographs
are truly remarkable and
like i said you know everyone is a fan
of of duane's obviously and that
includes uh me and everybody on my show
so i appreciate you taking the time
oh and thank you so much man i've been a
fan of yours for a long time and uh keep
doing your thing and thanks again for
the support i really appreciate it no
it's my pleasure and if you say thank
you i guess the way that i need to
finish is what can i
say except you're welcome
[Laughter]
yeah well said my friend well said you
know
my daughter would kill me if i didn't
finish the interview this way so
yeah thanks for thanks for doing this i
love it
thank you so much rich thanks again